a 20 versos 1 un padre escoge las hijas
de su hija
confiarías en tu padre para escoger tus
citas
soy 6 estudia relaciones internacionales
en la universidad de san diego y mi papá
vino conmigo hoy y me llamo clyde y soy
el líder de una ong religiosa papá que
estarás evaluando hoy personalidad
deseos e intereses todo lo importante
altura tal vez mismo metro ochenta
probablemente me gusta incluir a todos
así que excluir a alguien sólo por su
apariencia no no me gusta
primera ronda elegir padre versus hija
el padre conocer a 20 chicos y señalar a
la derecha para pasarlos a la siguiente
ronda oa la izquierda para eliminarlos
pero no sabe que 6 hizo lo mismo
[Música]
elecciones de 6
puedo ofrecerte si
puedo abrazarte
[Risas]
[Música]
puedo abrazarte
pues por la altura
[Risas]
puedo abrazarte claro por supuesto
muy bien
tú eliges
gracias
a la izquierda
[Música]
pero también
tú igual
y tú también
o igual
si pasa
muy bien a la izquierda
muy bien si ve a la izquierda pasa por
aquí
elecciones del padre elecciones fue muy
duro
creo que nada
incómodo no todos merecen ser vistos
llamados y les dice fue horrible para
para juzgar a los chicos según su
apretón de manos y presentación
es un placer señor como pegamos me llamo
cárter y usted robert sweet light se
parece a steve martin
tardando mucho
lo siento voy a la derecha
hola soy justin justin si soy rey dan un
plazo hayan por aquí hola soy al al
como este señor soy william daley me
llamo clive es un igualmente para
complacer soy gay grave es un gusto
igualmente por aquí
tailandia como el país me encanta
gracias bien
sí porque no soy sec es un quehacer por
aquí
su única mica puedo abrazarte por
unos abrazos y melvin tiene una hermosa
sonrisa
en la derecha
soy artur artur me das un abrazo
artur me parecía lindo
en sus zapatos y su acento y mi nombre
es jeter jeter y clive light a la
derecha hola soy rico
me dio algunas señales como hay algunos
buenos ahí lo intenté pero no estoy muy
seguro mi papá sabe cuál es mi tipo
pensé que lo haría bien claro y luego
realmente quedé sorprendida la tercera
ronda entre violas de nuevo tu nombre
era kate soy ryan bryant sé que voy bien
sab háblame de ti vivo en nueva york que
estudió industria musical am soy músico
y también videógrafo en mi tiempo libre
hago artes marciales voy a empezar a
estudiar química en la universidad estoy
estudiando para ser paramédico pero mi
meta a largo plazo de ser bombero así me
veo en 5 años
estudió finanzas en la universidad de
maryland trabajó como consultor
actualmente y
sólo porque estudias en maryland ve a la
derecha estudiando que lo soy así de
claro que lo soy
porque lo hice lo siento creo que fue mi
instinto me llamo william estudio en la
universidad de maryland tara bueno
intento es cierto en serio así es en
colegio el campus donde vives de gijón
muy bien
a la derecha
no lo pensé lo siento hija lo siento
podría decirse que soy bueno jugando
golf si quiere jugar algún día
necesita un compañero así que no sé
jugar golf pero puedo enseñarle a
háblame de tu familia a mi madre es de
la india solíamos ir de visita todos los
años con ella y la admiro por muchas
razones mi padre es doctor aprecio mucho
mi relación con él ahora que estoy aquí
dime algo de tu vida romántica
nunca me ha gustado iniciar ningún tipo
de relación si no me siento preparado
para hacerlo ahora si me siento
preparado para una porque estás en este
episodio
vine aquí porque quiero enamorarme y
conocer un buen papá
seré honesto empecé un negocio hace poco
y quiero que más gente empiece a conocer
mi ros entiendo si es mejor decir la
verdad de siempre es muy bien puedo
abrazarte por supuesto
un placer conocer a buen chico puedo
abrazarte
así
gracias muy bien al haber iglesias
jeaustin es la derecha pasa por aquí
muchas gracias está bien porque aquí
rápido gracias derecha de nada gracias
señor sí señor
a tu papá le costó eliminar más chicos
no me sorprende sólo sólo elimine a 12
no tengo idea le haré dos preguntas a
todos los chicos hábleme sobre su vida
espiritual o fe y cuál es su opinión
acerca de la crisis fronteriza entre
rusia y ucrania
vaya dos preguntas están listos tú
luego de ir al gimnasio me gusta meditar
y hacer yoga no tengo una gran vida
espiritual creo que tengo la mente
bastante abierta pero el cristianismo es
lo que me ha hecho entender quién es
dios me criaron en el budismo pero casi
todos mis amigos son cristianos así que
soy muy abierto creciendo pero crecí en
un país musulmán así que sé mucho del
islam y otras religiones me parece
importante y conocerlas toda mi familia
es cristiana yo también soy cristiano
pregunta 2 no me gusta la presencia de
rusia en ucrania
sé que empezó por crimea no y creo que
deberían dejarlos en paz rusia ya es
grande sé que rusia está intentando
adentrarse a ucrania y decir que la
gente ahí habla ruso para atacar y creo
que eso causaría un problema en europa
si mal no recuerdo rusia quiere invadir
ucrania yo no sé mucho del tema pero me
encantaría que me explicaran no conozco
mucho del tema debería investigar más no
conozco el tema no sé tanto como para
opinar no sé lo suficiente como para
opinar así que no responderé no quiero
decirle cualquier cosa
lo siento por allá a la derecha por aquí
a la derecha a la derecha gracias a la
derecha tuve a la derecha por aquí muy
bien
cree que uno de estos chicos le gustará
a su hija el padre debe elegir a un
finalista para su hija
sí muy bien
hola cómo te fue
creo que me dejé llevar
demasiadas está bien
cuando hablo sobre la vida y las citas
no puedo evitar pensar que el tipo de
chico que eliges se parecerá a tu futuro
esposo esto no se trata de matrimonio
acuerdo pero la dirección con la que
empieza será la misma con la que
continuarás así que debería salir con
personas con potencial creo que te
gustará esta persona creo que lo
encontrarás ha puesto muy bien es
posible que tengan una conexión a nivel
espiritual de acuerdo
hay una sorpresa
algo extra genial esperaré a que el
mismo te lo diga suena excelente bien
[Música]
cuál será la sorpresa
ah
cuál es la sorpresa
asumo que estudió en la universidad de
maryland y
entiendo si
no mi papá es de maryland con rodero ha
ido a marilyn a donde no recuerdo tenía
12 como muchos cangrejos del señor exige
gracias pero en vacaciones idea nueva
york nos vemos allá bien perfecto suena
bien gracias fue un placer igualmente me
das tu - y déjame es bebible estoy
sorprendida es más bajo que yo pero
entendí lo de maryland y tiene ojos
hermosos
ya veremos es que tu padre eligió a
alguien con quien le gustaría pasar el
rato probablemente siento que se llevo
bien con todos hace un rato con los
chicos y me encantaría conocerlo es
mejor porque todos son increíbles y
creativos y conocer personas y escuchar
sus historias es la mejor parte de la
vida amo a mi papá hace que todos se
sientan queridos le darás una
oportunidad a su elección sí claro tiene
mi número depende de él se nota que es
un buen chico ya veremos estoy abierta a
salir con él sí
[Música]
[Risas]
a
los terrenos si
no te molesta es mejor que nos deje
bailar solos bien
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 bien 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
[Risas]
vamos de nuevo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
no sé más
lo hicimos bien eres profesor solo me
divertía la canción no dura mucho estuvo
bien gracias me encantó bien me enseñó
buenos pasos fue interesante en negra sí
lo fue